الرئيس السابق يتحدث عن
سلطته الأساسية
في الإذاعة هذا الصباح ، فأنا أقدم
التأييد
وأنا أؤيد الناس بأنني
كنت أفيدنا وأن هذا
مفيد للحزب الجمهوري وأنهم صوتوا في
طريقنا وإذا كانوا "  لقد قلت شيئًا ما
بعيدًا عن اللون بالنسبة لي ، أعني أنه
يمكنني التعامل مع ذلك إذا صوتوا بطريقتنا ،
لذا فأنا أؤيد بعض الأشخاص الذين
أعتقد أنهم كانوا جيدين
جدًا وسيفوزون جميعًا
وسيذهبون  للفوز بالمعلق السياسي الكبير في
CNN ، إيسي كوب
موجود هنا معنا الآن حسنًا ، فهل هذا
ما سيبدو عليه الموسم التمهيدي الجمهوري
وهل هناك أي احتمال أن
يعني
ذلك أن ما يمكن أن يكون عادةً بعض
المقاعد الجمهورية الآمنة سيكون معرضًا للخطر
أو هل ترى  هذا يعني
أننا سننتهي بمزيد من مارجوري تايلور
غرينز في الكونجرس ،
حسنًا ، أعتقد أن هذا حقًا
من نواح كثيرة يصل إلى دونالد ترامب
ومدى
تأثيره وكيف
لا يزال مؤثرًا
وصدقني أه أنت  أعرف  أنا
لا يوجد أحد على هذا الكوكب يريد
أن يكون في الماضي
ترامب ، آه أكثر مما أفعل ولكننا لم نصل إلى
هناك بعد وقد رأينا
خلال الشهرين الماضيين
تأثير أشخاص مثل مارجوري
تايلور
جرين ينمو والناس  مثل
أن تكون ليز تشيني مهمشة ومهمشة نوعًا ما
، علينا
أن نرى
كيف يغير ذلك أننا لم
نتجاوز ترامب حتى الآن ،
ونفكر فيما إذا كان ذلك يثقل كاهله
في هذه الانتخابات التمهيدية أو
يحاول نوعًا ما الزحف للخلف  على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي أو
القيام بأي نوع من الحزم التي
سيبدأ كل هذا سيكون من
المهم مشاهدتها